oh
what's that noise what's that in the
distance it's probably a cannonball it's
probably a shark right yeah
you never know what these shows
what
oh now that's my point oh that's hot as
hell i mean bareback riding is always
fun but i like the savage oh no that
would hurt also i'm so glad if they
didn't have a dragon they'd all be
swallowed up right now just imagine
being one of the fighters and being like
goddamn
two dragons
how are we gonna get out of this yeah
yeah buddy give me that burn give it
your birthday you're burnt give me that
egg i'd be like why am i here we're not
gonna fight a dragon i'd be scared
she's such a boss she is and then he
throws the egg to her
oh flimsy like not recognizing it's the
most valuable thing on all of earth
welcome back to new rock stars there may
be a new heir to the throne in king's
landing but she's not wearing the crown
just yet there's still plenty of way too
young women for the king to marry and
that means a new baby boy which we saw
in the trailer
you know hbo loves doing that after the
show they do a little teaser of what's
gonna happen next week uh this could all
just spell trouble for westeros first
female ruler obviously they're getting
ready to push her out for someone else
this is a big question presents talking
dragons our weekly after show for all
fantasy needs look at that look at that
little graphic
look at that graphic
i'm jessica clemens here with me today
is brandon barrick oh hello yeah so
happy to be back uh and man we got some
talking dragons this episode they were
really saying hello to each other like
hi michelle
also yeah what do you think these
dragons are saying when it's like damn
dude you got taken away from our yeah
man i'm straight up here you owe me 50
dollars yeah
if you step over here though i'm going
to bite you
i'm just doing what she tells me to do
yeah i'll just do it
if you tune in today and you're looking
for a regular big question it will be
back soon there's just so much fantasy
to cover right now we're focusing all of
our big questions in that realm of
fantasy and today we are talking about
house of dragons episode two now we
won't be spoiling anything that could be
coming from the book that it's based on
fire and blood if we need to reference
things from fire and blood we will but
we won't spoil anything that might be
foretold in that ancient tome uh but
that being said let's do a quick recap
of house of the dragon episode 2 the
rogue prince uh we get a new title
sequence set to a very familiar tune how
fun was that and the rivers of blood
flowing through the streets can't be
good foreshadowing at all folks they
call him the crab feeder for a reason
and the sailors of the stepstones are
what's being served on this crustacean
buffet and it is pissing lord corliss
off he's having none of it as master of
ships he's like we gotta clean up these
harbors boys uh meanwhile rhaenyra is
still just a cup bearer for the small
council even though it's been six months
since the last episode when she was
named air
rhaenyra listens in on cordless
complaints during the council and
interjects to suggest sending the dragon
riders to deal with the pirates but she
gets sent off to deal with some filling
a vacancy on the kingsguard instead they
don't want to hear it from a woman uh
it's clear nobody wants her to be yeah
uh they're like don't talk and then even
there they're like oh god now we're
still not happy i was like stop giving
her a task if you're not gonna be happy
yeah yeah so she was given this task and
she deals with it her own way when she
realizes that most of these knights
who've come to join the kingsguard uh
they haven't fought anything tougher
than a poacher or a drunken melee at a
tournament
except for one familiar face good old
beautiful sir kristin cole remember him
uh what a beautiful man uh he's seen
some real battles out there he's fought
he's fought the real fights uh and
rainier is all about him joining the
kingsguard due to his actual combat
experience
uh otto hightower however is wary of the
politics of such a decision but rhaenyra
gets her way as she most often does uh
alison is still hanging around vasiras
providing comfort and listening to the
history of valeria he asked her about
rhaenyra since he's too afraid to talk
to her himself uh but he also wants to
keep his talks with alison on the dl
they're just talks right they're just
toxic you know when you're asking for it
to be on the dl it's not just it's not
it it's weary it's weird and he should
have just confronted her straight up
about it yeah even though i think there
was that conversation and we just didn't
see it because clearly when she when he
was like i'm gonna marry this one she
wasn't surprised yeah she was surprised
uh and it's clear i love how he says
like he'd rather deal with a dragon than
talk to his 15 year old daughter true
which is very funny and i think most
fathers feel that way real talk real
time i am literally 15 i was two dragons
uh
i was too drunk uh but alice said you
know she's she's making moves of her own
uh and she remains close to rhaenyra and
they still are getting along they share
a nice moment together in the sound yeah
but it was all she tries to evangelize
it was planned it was all schemed and i
loved it she was like hey sometimes you
have to make the effort to talk to your
dad yes i do and i'm like yeah girl
you're trying she's like out of nowhere
no one told me to say this but you need
to talk to your dad i love her uh
viserys meets with uh raynes and corliss
uh sure reassuring them of his loyalty
uh corliss warns viserys though of the
many dangers threatening his reign they
both urge him to act and also suggest
joining their families by marrying their
very young daughter lady lyanna uh this
would join the houses of targaryens of
valeron
combining their dragon might and naval
superiority really securing via uh
viserys's reign uh otto hears about this
later and says it's a complete overreach
by corliss because we know he's trying
to get his own daughter in there uh the
grand maester however he likes the idea
he loves the idea of viserys marrying uh
lady lana uh and he really pushes him
and says don't worry about rhaenyra who
cares what she thinks uh it's clear the
grand maester like most of the men in
the realm want uh the king to marry
again and get a male heir out there uh
they do not want rhaenyra ascending the
throne that's for sure
vasaris and rhaenyra give uh talking a
try they try and work it out but it's a
little awkward sure
it's all working out yeah yeah and she
brings up what happened at the small
council and he's like stop stop i don't
talk about it they're not getting along
they can't find that common ground uh
lady lyanna she she herself gives the
hard cell to viserys as a very
sharp 20 year old or 12 year old look at
that wig clear clearly coached by her
parents uh it definitely creeps viserys
out a little bit uh but alison is not
having any of this she's still making
moves of her own uh having a broken
dragon figurine fixed up for the
valerian model and we i know this men
love action figures oh do that the way
to a man's heart is an action figure so
the next time a man breaks his like lego
set if i rebuild it oh if you fixed my
lego set we'd get married immediately
immediately okay uh rhaenyra and reynos
trade some barbs of their own uh but
reynolds takes the opportunity to remind
rainier that the men of westeros will
never let her take the throne she's very
bitter the queen that never was uh
rainier even calls her that to her face
yes which is a little harsh but she
knows what it's like out there and uh
they're not gonna let it happen and i
think we know that to be true but what
about the best character of the show
prince damon uh well he never went back
to his wife at runestone which is i
really want to meet this wife at
runestone instead he took over
dragonstone with his dragon karaxis and
his mistress massaria and now prince
damon has stolen a dragon egg he wants
to make messaria his second wife a very
big targaryen tradition having multiple
wives
he claims that she's pregnant and he
needs a dragon egg for the baby uh again
more tradition from the targaryen family
he invites his brother to the wedding
how sweet it's in two days not much
notice uh rhaenyra wants to know which
egg is missing she immediately catches
on to this and it turns out it's one of
dreamfire's eggs a very famous dragon uh
it was also the egg that she picked out
for her brother baelon who didn't make
it as we remember from that traumatizing
first episode uh viserys he he gets up
for this he's ready to go and get it
back but otto hightower steps in to take
on the mission on his behalf otto does
not want viserys dying with rhaenyra set
to take the throne so he's like i will
put my life on the line and go get this
i got a lot of stuff going on don't
screw this up for me uh he heads out to
dragonstone with sir kristin cole and a
garrison of knights and now we're at
dragonstone baby and damon is pissed his
brother didn't show up otto hightower
talked some trash to damon's fiance to
her face tough stuff the swords come out
but so does karaxis uh an auto hightower
in the line of the episode sheath the
effing steel put it away boys you're not
gonna kill a dragon not with a bunch of
stories would he cuss them out this is
stupid but when he did cuss them out i
was like damn calm down
i could put it away i understand you're
angry he's not ready to die on that
bridge he's like put those swords away
we're not going to have this fight uh
despite otto not bringing a dragon to a
dragon fight you always got to do that
my guy ramirez shows up on the back of
cyrax coming out of the clouds beautiful
stuff uh hightower's surprised to see
her there rhaenyra calls damon out on
his bs and dares damon to kill her i
thought that was a baller move uh
instead like a little b boy he gives
back the dragon egg
tosses it to her with a little
and rhaenyra gets a w and makes all the
boys look like little girls i think uh i
love it uh it was great a great moment
for her
damon takes the walk of shame to his
lady who is beginning to realize that
she is butt upon in this game of thrones
as they say it turns out damon was
bluffing about the pregnancy and the
wedding he's not even there to marry her
ugh tough stuff for my guy becerras
plays with his dragon and runs through
his uh his wife prospects and even goes
to talk to someone else lord lionel
strong who also pushes viserys to
consider corliss's offer very carefully
remember the sea he's the seat the sea
snake and he's made a very smart play
here uh he knows that like by offering
this to viserys he really needs to take
it or he's going to create a lot of
problems uh news arrives that rhaenyra
has returned from dragonstone no one
knew that she was going there otto
didn't know vasara said no but serious
is pissed but you can also tell that
he's proud of his daughter who managed
to deal with this situation pretty
swiftly uh they finally come to
an understanding when they talk about
the death of emma uh her mother uh and
the grief that they both share and
vasara seems to indicate that he would
never go back on naming her heir but he
makes it pretty clear that he needs a
backup plan and he's expected to get
married again so it's kind of like oh i
love you you'll always be the heir but i
also need to get married again yeah it's
also like it's like it's like you're
always you're always gonna be there and
i'm like okay so if you get married
again you have a child that's a son
you're really not going to push me to
the side you're going to let everyone in
your council say like no no
yeah like no
that's i think that's what might become
and that's what she i think she
recognized that she even knew it she was
like yeah she knows it was kind of like
a mutual agreement but i think they're
both still at odds and don't trust each
other at all
at the next small council meeting
viserys names his new wife and it is
lady allison hightower shocked and
amazed we all are uh corliss is not
pleased to hear this news and rhaenyra
is clearly not happy about it either so
having been spurned by his king corliss
meets with damon to get some help with
this at the step stones and keep these
shipping lanes moving and get this crab
feeder dead
they're both brothers of kings second
sons uh corliss reminds damon that quote
worth is not given it must be made what
a line to end the episode and so the
table gets set for damon's next move i'm
not trying to be a butt to viserys but
all you need to do is pull out a dragon
and once damon pulls out that dragon
first they're going to notice who's
actually worthy and who does the amount
of actual work it's interesting we're
going to talk about this more today but
it's clear that viserys is so afraid of
the dragons
oh he's so terrified i'm so afraid of
them uh but before we get to all that we
want to remind you to be sure to check
out newrockstarsmerch.com
to grab our newest latest obsession
shirt inspired by house of the dragon
called ash and ruin this limited edition
shirt won't be available for long so be
sure to grab it while you still can and
when you purchase this latest obsession
shirt you unlock the opportunity to get
a custom shout out that will appeal that
will appear right here on our talking
dragons after show and we may even uh
talking dragon it ourself i'll be a
talking dragon right now uh this is from
marcos in jacksonville florida and or in
jacksonville florida ristas noah rosie
marco isas
i don't know what i just said sounded
more like a star wars
i think that sounded more like a star
wars that was some some pure uh westeros
uh language there for you uh another
shout out we got red and black dragon
you know randroid had to get one of
these shirts that was from randy ray aka
refers to himself as android good for
you android and also i love you michelle
nuts evadahn happy anniversary from
joshua
i mean i don't i don't know you but i
love you as well
happy anniversary uh and before we get
to uh our first big question for today
uh a word from one of our sponsors uh
and they wanna know what's holding you
back from the ultimate gaming experience
is it the hundreds of dollars it costs
for you to set up or are you the busy
on-the-go type with only minutes to
spare well you know what you can level
up your game with backbone the universal
gaming essential that instantly enhances
your gaming experience on mobile
backbone just released a playstation
edition of their beloved backbone one we
have one right here we've been playing
with it uh the officially licensed
controller for playstation was brought
to life in collaboration with the
playstation design team oh isn't it
lovely the elegant colors materials and
finishes are all inspired by the design
of the ps5 dual sense controller all the
way down to the transparent face buttons
and its visually distinctive floating
appearance keep that screen clean uh all
you got to do is plug your iphone into
the backbone and enjoy console qual
console quality controls as you play
console games via remote play or cloud
streaming service and the app store
games uh i've never myself liked playing
console games on my phone
until i got a backbone it was always
annoying using the like
uh just the screen and the controls on
the screen
it's nice to have like something that
feels like a real controller the buttons
uh it's so much easier and much more
precise go to back go to
playbackbone.com big question now to
order your backbone for a limited time
and get free access to over 350 console
games and perks we just got jessica one
this morning she was already blown away
by all the games that were on there yeah
i'm not playing minecraft and also
there's a lot of playstation in xbox
games yeah there's tons of games you can
play there backbone is now the official
partner of diablo immortal not only is
the game specifically optimized for
backbone but you will also receive ten
dollars of in-game perks find your next
adventure at playbackbone.com
bigquestion that's playbackbone.com
targaryen dragons every now and then
they're they're used to seeing them it's
not a big deal dragons we know them we
love them they're great uh viserys
though warns that the dragons will be
the downfall of the targaryens right uh
but how far away is all that it all
leads us to this week's big question
how significant is this specific dragon
egg that we see in this episode i think
it's going to come back again in an
important way yeah okay we learned that
this dragon egg that damon purloined was
in fact the egg that rhaenyra had picked
out for her little brother so has a ton
of significance
damon didn't even have a baby to give
this to was just being a little prick
about it wanted to get his brother's
attention wanted to cause some like
stress show how his brother's an
ineffective leader uh but this egg
specifically was an egg from dream fire
now dream fire is like an important
dragon in the lineage of the targaryens
uh she was the dragon of rhaenyra
targaryen who played a role in the
overthrow of maegor the conqueror maegor
was the bloodthirsty ruler just before
jahiris the concilitator uh so
dreamfire's an important dragon do we
think that this that the dragon that
hatches out of this egg eventually could
play a role in the downfall of damon
wouldn't that be some weird poetic
justice
that would be great also i just think
it's uh
i think they're raised to understand the
importance of the dragons and how very
special they are and how they what they
mean to them so i think it's like hey
this is my dead brother's dragon yeah
yeah and you stole it from me yeah just
like his life was taken from mine like
why would you do this but also
i know that not a lot of people have
killed dragons but it's still like when
a dragon dies how are they gonna get
another one right and they can't
eliminate all these yeah it's a limited
supply you can't just keep losing these
dragons and plus losing it to damon of
all people he would train that dragon
he's already fly by itself and kill him
he's already taken of dragon yeah he's
taken care of
um the meanest looking dragon in the
entire show so far well it's interesting
you bring up if a dragon dies how do you
replace it because viserys when he's
talking about valeria the old days
before the doom there were thousands of
jackets he said
and we know the dragons are powerful
they're basically the nukes of westeros
whoever's got the dragons controls the
land but like viserys is so
gun-shy of these things like when ronera
speaks up uh and says like let's send
the dragon you got dragon riders let's
go kill the pirates right now he's like
no i don't want to start a war i don't
want a thing it's like you have the most
powerful weapon no one can stand against
you now their dragons have been killed
yes yes uh you know during aegon's
conquering one got shot out of the sky
you know it happens uh but
he's so afraid of these dragons and the
way he's like you know
the metaphor of like the broken dragon
statue
allison fixes it but the way he's like
holding it and like he's just afraid of
them he is a fan and also he doesn't get
on them like he doesn't like his
daughter has one his brother has one
he's just not even trying to even look
at him really you know i i understand
that fear of and also i love that line
at the end where damon was like my
brother was never good at being a king
right so and it's true it's like he
doesn't know how to use his own weaponry
and he doesn't want to he's like
everything's calm why start something
and it's like well stuff is starting
with us and we can't move out the way
yeah so i think he's just afraid of the
dragons which is fine i guess but
yeah both damon and rhaenyra they love
the dragon they speak high valerian to
each other all the time it was cool
seeing viserys speak high valeria yeah i
know that he at least knows the language
and i like that like the dragon trainers
that's maybe all they speak is like high
valerian which is like kind of fun
like they're entrusted to work with
these dragons do you think it was emma's
doing that it's like why uh his daughter
is so into the culture and so highly
involved that and he's not where he's
like taken out of it or do you think
it's just because he's a king that he
just kind of like loves to go to the
wayside it's interesting like you
pointed out he doesn't have a dragon
right now but seriously he was uh
belleron's last rider belleron was the
dragon that aegon the conqueror used to
take over westeros it was maegor's
dragon the black dread they called it uh
and viserys kind of was like you know
this was a hand-me-down dragon that was
like the most powerful in the land that
he was given and he was like the last
one on it and he was like
i have a dragon and then it was over and
he was like i don't want a new dragon
it's okay uh but speaking of belleron
they kind of also when he's talking with
lady elena
they bring up vegar who was the partner
dragon to belayer on who is still out
there somewhere uh this is a chekhov's
gun for sure this dragon's coming back
yeah well
yes it's like that dragon's gonna come
back and kill everybody not carrying
who's yeah yeah because it's a dragon
and you can't tame a dragon like he said
at the beginning uh i don't think it or
it's just gonna get killed i don't think
it's ever gonna come back and be
controlled i don't know i mean i i i
think you're right there i don't think
anyone's going to get on this dragon
again
but it is going to come back and it's
going to play a role uh uh veigar was
the partner dragon to belleron like i
said and it was also take took place of
aegon the conquerors conquering of the
seven kingdoms uh and it was written by
aegon's wife slash sister very targaryen
uh visenya uh who she also wielded dark
sister so there's a lot of parallels
here because damon has dark sister right
now uh he's acting very much like maegor
we're seeing a lot of like similarities
between those two trying to have
multiple wives trying to take the the
crown from his brother like all these
similarities are coming back so i really
think vegard is gonna play a big role
here i can't wait to see him yeah this
whole segment of history is called the
dance of the dragons that's true that is
true the dance has begun i mean rainier
coming out on the bridge and saying like
kill me right now yeah go ahead would it
be king so bad go ahead okay and then my
dragon's gonna move your ass my dragon's
gonna get you
i love when they were like they were
like escorter and she was like my dragon
doesn't want to touch me yeah i have fun
you better ask my dragon first there was
so many clapbacks in this episode from
different women and i was so even when
she was fighting with her cousin like
even when the or the the queen that
never was i was like she's shut up but
then i was also like but i was also like
go off queen that never was it's true i
was like i would be scorned as hell yeah
i i think like right near rainer she's
smart she is tactical but she's still
young and she can
otto hightower telling her like oh don't
pick sir chris and cole you're gonna
piss off this house in that house and
she's like i'm gonna pick him anyways i
feel like otto was kind of pushing her
to do that in a way in a roundabout way
he knows that that's going to create a
problem later and so he's he's letting
right here make that mistake and he's
almost like prodding her to make that
mistake otto's a very shrewd man i don't
try i don't trust otto what you said
because he the king is like this is my
best friend it's like yeah i mean damon
has pointed out how the king is so
easily swayed
uh
and i think otto is playing him like a
little fiddle i don't want to be this
person the world will be better once the
king's dead
i
we got a lot of kings to go through
before the world gets any better and a
lot more maggot wounds to talk about uh
but first we should thank a couple other
sponsors here of talking dragons today
uh whether you're the king of westeros
or the owner of a small business you've
got to be ready for expansion baby
you've got to be ahead of the game when
it comes to logistics whether that's
sending out ships to deal with the crab
feeder or making sure you're ready to
handle all the online orders pouring in
these holiday seasons uh whether you're
starting small or scaling up shipstation
makes ship happen no more limiting your
business to one store shipstation
integrates with every platform including
amazon etsy ebay shopify etc making it
easy to manage all of your shipping from
one simple dashboard maximize your sales
with minimal effort and save time with
consolidated order management and
automated shipping updates for your
customers easily compare carriers rates
and delivery times to get the most out
of every send get the same discounted
shipping rates as fortune 500 companies
whether you're sending a stack or a
truck full join over 130 000 companies
that's so many companies who have grown
their ecommerce businesses with
shipstation 98 of companies that use
shipstation for one year become
customers for life 98
what a rate what a rate uh shipstation
has handled the shipping needs for
customers like chubby shorts i got a
pair of chubbies
conscious box offerman works woodshop
you know nick offerman he's great daily
look and on it and so many more ship
more and grow more with shipstation go
to shipstation.com today and sign up
with promo code big question for a free
60-day trial start today and get set up
before the biggest shipping season of
the year it's just around the corner
that's two months for free visit
shipstation.com click the microphone at
the top and type in code big question
uh and unless you're cordless valeron
we've all been in need of a little cash
every now and then i know i myself have
uh there's nothing wrong with that
hindsight is 20 20 and you can't change
the pass but what if you could get a
little help from your future self maybe
you'd ask to borrow a little cash huh
maybe future self can you send it
through time thank you so much now you
can with dave dave is the banking app
that can help you get up to 500
instantly with extra cash that's more
money to fill your tank buy a wedding
gift or catch up on bills you can
finally tackle those expenses that have
been stressing you out without any
hang-ups there's no interest and no
credit check needed millions of people
have already downloaded the dave app to
get the financial relief they need with
extra cash so if you're in a pinch and
need some extra help download dave and
think of it as a helping hand from
future you download dave today at
dave.com bigquestion that's dave.com
bigquestion sign up for an extra cash
account and get up to 500 instantly for
terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal instant transfer fees applies
banking provided by evolve member fdic
future you will thank you
perfect okay jessica let's talk about
another big question i had coming out of
this episode and it's one i'm gonna have
every week until one of these issues
gets resolved who is a bigger threat to
peace here is it the crab peter or is it
sir christian cole i don't trust
christian call at all he's too pretty
he's up to something but this crab
feeder guy's got to be done with it i
think it's the crab feeder but i also
think the crab feeder is the easiest the
thing is
he's a proxy right every yeah and
everything is easy once you use the
dragon right so it's like none of these
these things are so miniscule once you
actually use a dragon for right now i do
think it's the crab feeder absolutely
they are literally making it doing a
demonstration of how easy it is to kill
us like they are hammering people to
like sticks and then letting crabs feed
upon their flesh and just being like
look at what we're doing to your people
like that's horrible and it looks
horrible for your kids it's very
dramatic it's very dramatic so dramatic
well you know the king viserys he's wary
of war he doesn't want to whip the
dragons out uh and he's afraid of going
to battle with like the free cities he
says that's true and they warned her
about that one we don't want to get into
this mess so it's going to be a whole
host of problems and from for most of
the time the free cities kind of just
like war with each other but now they're
kind of united in a very interesting way
and these are the problems that can pop
up when you have so much peace for so
long right people have time if they're
not fighting other wars they have time
to think about like how could i start a
war oh really i do hate this
i do hate this guy pisses me off uh and
it's clear that like this whole crab
feeder thing has really pissed off
corliss who's like losing money here
he's the money bags in this situation i
completely agree with cory yes he's
being totally discounted he is being
completely discounted if he's the one
with all the money you don't want to
upset the banker that makes no sense to
be like i'm still your king and it's
like i have the money i could walk away
and still have the people and the money
behind me you're out of your mind yeah
so he's the sea snake he's the merchant
of the ships like he's got the neighbors
you need this guy you need him why piss
him off like i get like not taking his
daughter's hand but this like go and go
fight you have to go fight i thought i
thought him and uh his wife put up a
pretty good argument as to why
vassar should marry a 12 year old i'm
not going to say that's a good idea it
makes sense and i but okay so it makes
sense it completely makes like join the
houses keep the power for that time and
also it just makes sense too but i'm i
just and i understand with him i'm like
i couldn't only because i told you i'd
be reading this girl a book every night
i mean i'd have to treat her like i had
a second daughter i don't want her until
she was 15. yeah that's my whole thing
was i was like well maybe he could marry
her and just have a second wife
and not do anything with that child well
i mean that's the thing they're giving
damon a hard time for taking a second
wife
uh so he can't he can't pull the same
move well what if he had he took okay i
don't think they would have done this he
takes lady elena okay and then has a
child with someone else and then
pretends it's lady elena
okay i guess lady elena at one point
could straight up be like that's not my
child yeah i'm surprised he wasn't
trying to get
a giant like a a bastard in there
somehow and kind of it seemed like they
didn't care they didn't really care if
it was as long as a boy they just wanted
well there's a thing in in game of
thrones uh where like when you get
married you have an audience for your
consummation that evening uh now granted
from then on out you don't have an
audience every time unless you ask for
it uh but uh i'm sure he doesn't want to
have that situation going on i mean that
was some heavy stuff uh you know corliss
and reynos they are
you know
they're trying to get power any way they
can yeah and man offering up their 12
year old daughter and the idea that
they're having this conversation with
her like all right here's what you got
to say to viserys to win him over don't
worry you can wait she's like i want to
go outside
and play with a ball
get in there and play with something all
right all right no absolutely not
absolutely
and it made it worse seeing that child
with that big ass wig i was like that is
a little child i i was almost scared
because i was like if i see him kiss
this shot i'm turning this off and i'm
never watching i was glad to see how
kind of put off the whole situation he
was he was like i'm not into this at all
but i do understand the merging of the
houses yeah it sucks that their eldest
daughter is 12. yeah because if she was
like 15 16 no problem yeah he would have
taken it but
look look at her look at her she's too
young and she's so sweet she didn't want
it too sweet she doesn't wanna she
wasn't doing it she also doesn't want to
marry her brother who that could be on
the cards too who knows uh
but yeah sir kristen cole i think is
gonna be a big problem for someone i
mean otto hightower warned of like how
this is gonna piss off some other houses
some other families but this guy i don't
know if i trust him at all i think he's
gonna just die and i think he's gonna
get the death that like rob got like i
think it's just gonna be
he's gonna be unexpected too virtuous
and it's gonna cost him yeah i i i
really am banking on him um like
having a strong connection with uh the
daughter and era uh but like
i just think it's it's gonna hit it's
gonna happen i was not surprised
allison's gonna get like a wandering eye
oh and like after she's married after
you got it yeah and this guy's me in the
king's guard he's gonna round the king
all the time
uh well okay so i mean even rainer when
she was like stepping on the edge to
like lean over and look at him i was
like this is a problem everyone's it's
like um
it's it's like imagine if you were
dating harry styles it's like yeah
everyone's gonna be attracted to him all
the time my child my sister my aunt i
can't take him anywhere can't take him
anywhere also did we ever discuss
whether or not emma we knew emma had a
lot of problems with uh with uh having a
baby a lot of miscarriages but could it
have also been
uh viserys
who was that yeah that was the problem
because watch with allison maybe she
does pull a situation where she takes
yes sir kristen cole and is like hey
i need to have a child let him sire the
child yeah because i say it's yours yeah
whoa spicy spicy that's some handmade
[ __ ] well either way we got to deal with
the crab feeder we got to deal with
kristin cole someone's got to deal with
these problems hopefully the crap it
looks like next week we're going to deal
with the crab feeder a little bit but
it's easy to take him out just take him
out i think he is like a proxy clearly
they kind of brought this up on the show
like who's paying this guy who's funding
this
is he is he making money off of nailing
these guys to post or is it that just
for funsies uh you know get these guys a
backbone so they can play with their
mobile devices otherwise you'd be
nailing people
to wood and leaving them on the beach uh
another question i i want to talk about
we're kind of already talking about this
already why does everyone want viserys
to marry lady elaine
uh it really empowers
house valeron so you wouldn't think all
these other people would be about about
it
well it's just the joining of both those
houses makes sense and plus it's still
the blood of the targaryens a little bit
so it's just like yeah this still works
for you guys it works with your
tradition and it works with the entire
kingdom like if you merge with the
richest strongest like weapon people or
like the shippers that is probably the
best idea it makes logical sense what is
he getting from otto like what is he
getting from the hot
otto was very smart he was the only one
who was like yo lord corliss he
overstepped he should have never offered
his daughter up like that that puts you
in a bad position because if you say no
it's going to piss him off but he's
saying that because he's secretly
working his daughter in august on the
slow burn and no one else seems to be
aware that that's going on yeah no one
warns viserys goes to all these people
basically looking for a reason not to
marry a 12 year old girl and everyone's
like nah marry a 12 year old girl
they'll be okay it'll be okay even the
maester i mean the maester he just
wanted he just wanted someone hates
right near it and he's like i don't care
if she's upset he doesn't know love with
a
wife or child so he's probably just like
i've been with a lot of babies
i mean he's like he's like what do you
mean what are you doing you care about
your daughter i kill a lot of children
every day yeah i also be like can i get
a new grand maester thanks so much
this guy's a failure uh he's i'm putting
my hand in maggots my wife is dead
what's going on yeah what if he was just
like putting his hands in the magazines
and they put his hands on the wife's
stomach
oh good lord good lord
the c-section would have been bacteria
i mean that that uh that moment of alice
and rhaenyra and the sept kind of showed
that rainer is not religious at all and
that's also why i think the grand
maester was like she could not be
she could not be queen because i need
someone who's like religious we need to
keep religio we need to keep the throne
and the church together alison is a
perfect queen yeah i don't think i don't
see so far from what i've seen allison
is loving caring adoring
she's a great literally what they want
from a queen is like someone that's like
quiet but beautiful and that's exactly
what allison is
yeah yeah i i don't know i mean it seems
like she's being manipulated by her dad
so much absolutely and there's obviously
the parallels you know her dad lost his
wife viserys has lost his wife he she
knows what a man going through that
grief is like she knows how to maybe
help them
but
and maybe she figures this is the best
outcome for her to marry the king and
not be you know put off with some other
lord who treats her awful and ships her
way to some faraway place and i think
she's just a woman that knows what she
wants i think we're giving her not
enough credit i think she recognizes her
dad is kind of a punk and she's just
like i'm going with what i gotta get out
of this yeah she's like i'm getting out
of this situation i don't care what
happens to my dad now and also to be
fair the only thing she had was her dad
if her dad died she's out of that tower
well she was probably very close with
her mom yeah i assume right i assume but
yeah that's a good point if her dad
loses anything they get a new hand and
then she goes yeah so he's a second son
so he has nothing like this he's trying
to build his own uh reputation oh well
wasn't that his son that was jousting
yeah he has a son but i'm saying otto is
a second oh yeah like damon had pointed
that out before uh
and i think like viserys going to all
these people and asking i think it's
still ringing in his head how damon said
like you're you're such a pushover you
do whatever anyone says so everyone
telling him to marry the little girl
he's like no i'm not gonna do it i'm
gonna marry allison and not warn my
daughter at all and just piss everybody
off couldn't even give her a little
give her a hand a little a little
whisper of like so your best friend yeah
i don't know i don't know what do we
make of viserys's never healing wounds
is this this is going to kill him right
it's got to be what kills him
he's going to lose a hand by the time
his baby comes yeah and it's just going
to be pieces of him getting chopped off
and he's going to die sooner than a lot
yeah also he should be dead by now um
not because i don't like him as a king
but because he's so injured yeah he
keeps getting injured by the throne it's
not a good look it's not a good metaphor
like his rotten finger i mean i clocked
that bandage early in the episode uh and
then you know they're doing their best
the flesh is rotting
it's not good it's not a good metaphor
for your king to be damaged by the very
throny city we're also afraid
of power yeah we're also assuming that
he's afraid of the dragons and doing all
these things i think he just doesn't
want to go outside and go to war yeah
because he will die immediately you know
everything is yeah he's just
everything's a hand-me-down to this guy
that's true even his little model kit
that he works so hard on he tells alice
that well this stone the stonemasons are
doing most of the hard work i tell you i
just sit down and when you show up i
come in and i act like i'm like oh damn
oh i'm working so hard on this allison
look at me yeah look at me it's like
when my wife comes in the room i'm like
98. 99 100. got him she says blasting
him stop why do you keep doing this why
are you yeah why do you keep doing this
this is a real stupid analogy and a
stupid comparison there is a great show
called attack on titan that literally
has them just like for hundreds and
hundreds of years just living until
these giants come and smash down their
city and i'm like this is exactly what
he's doing yeah he's just hanging out
until that final like he was like maybe
my great great grandson will have to
deal with it and it's like no dude it's
gonna be you it's coming sooner than you
think yeah and he also i mean i do i
love you know the reveal we had in the
first episode that like aegon and
conquer had this vision of the song in
ice and fire and viserys takes it to
heart we see in this episode he's still
carrying the blade that cat's paw like
valerian steel dagger that will
ultimately kill the night king he still
keeps it close like he's ready for that
he's worried about that he thinks the
dragons are gonna play a role in that in
a bad way i think because he and that's
kind of doomed we really don't know what
caused the doom but he sees the dragons
as part of that problem too many dragons
cause a big explosion right i think he's
afraid of the dragons now and he doesn't
know what to do
he doesn't command them his and he grew
up under his father during a time of
peace he does not know war at all we
talk about how these knights don't know
war this king doesn't know war yeah he
doesn't know how to conduct a war so
yeah you're right on the money he is
he's afraid of it all right he and he's
he's just kind of king and he's like
waiting his time and now he knows that
like he's a kind of a lame duck
everyone's like who's next who's next
you don't matter anymore and i know he's
afraid of damon targaryen uh why do we
think he chose allison ultimately is it
because everyone was recognized yeah i
think well i think they're like does he
really love do you think he has like a
lot of affection i think he has
affection for it i think he's he he has
a and i know this is gross i think he
has a soft spot for her because it
reminds him of his daughter i think it
reminds him of his daughter yeah and
he's like this is the closest i'm ever
going to get to my daughter is like the
love i have for you but luckily you're
not my daughter so i can do this great
great stuff and he's not related to her
you know that's a big bonus for a
targaryen i don't think he sees emma in
her but he definitely sees his own
daughter but genuinely i think since
everyone's rushing him to get married
there are like
three women in his life right now yeah
alison his daughter and his cousin yeah
he there is no one no he's the only one
not on his case yeah exactly
so it's like there's no one to choose
from other than if any and not enough
people are recommending their children
i'll be honest like we got one guy that
was like i have an 11 year old but she's
about to be 12. she looks like she's
eight here and i was like where is
everyone else's children at no one else
is giving like a 16 year old yeah yeah
so he didn't have that much to choose
from yeah he didn't he didn't have much
to choose from yeah she's not as pushy
uh and i think i think you're onto
something with the daughter stuff too
because he's so he doesn't know how to
talk to his own daughter and this is
like his way of talking to his daughter
in a weird
uh kind of once removed type way i i
don't know it's a weird psychology of
like
uh it's like the oedipus kind of thing
but it's with your daughter it's just
like well like i'm talking to her and
it's like this is not your daughter
it's a bad move of like well my daughter
likes her yeah they'll be good friends
they'll get along great old men that
hook up with their daughters best
friends don't do it yeah it never works
out it doesn't ever work out and your
daughter hates you for it forever yeah
don't do it don't do it uh we know in
the book fire and blood uh
rhaenyra and allison they weren't
friends necessarily they they kind of
meet later in the story so this was an
interesting choice by the show to make
them friends yeah i think it gives like
a really heavy backstory to it i really
like it i i'm not exactly sure of
allison's age we know right now is 15. i
thought she was in the book she's a
little older than rainier i don't know
how much older she is here but she's
maybe a little older but i think they're
trying to make them more like
contemporary than this so it is very
interesting uh do and i think do you
think
we mentioned how like this is maybe him
being close to his daughter do you think
there's a possibility that viserys made
this choice
almost a way of like because he doesn't
trust his daughter he's afraid of his
daughter
do you think by picking allison he's
kind of
taking a a person that his daughter
trusts and kind of moving him from her
side to his side
and this is a way of kind of keeping
that buffer between him and the thing is
he would have to be really stupid and he
is really stupid because they still kind
of don't trust each other yeah he does a
lot of ways i don't think no matter how
much this is his biological daughter
they are not father daughter no they're
not they're not at all so i think that's
why he's like oh she won't be hurt by it
and it's like no because that's still
you're still her like dad to her because
she's a child but you you aren't
treating her like that yeah he doesn't
know how to be a good dad yeah
absolutely which none of them at that
time usually yeah but otto is a horrible
dad yeah yeah they're being raised by
different people not by their you know
if your dad's the king you're not
hanging out with them a time usually you
know you're especially if you weren't
the initial heir if you were like the
fourth born son you weren't close with
your dad probably because he was busy
with the other kids that came first
maybe
maybe we get that at the beginning maybe
of like the second episode of like we
see how much she did try to like connect
yeah after mary and her dad
but it i if i was renera i'd be like i'm
not talking to
this is gonna talk you
me unless you cause some problems
it's gonna cause some problems you out
of your mind i told you and that's all
the thing i vented to you about
everything you know everything yeah she
knows all the yeah she knows all the
secrets for sure that's messed up yeah
it's dirty and i love allison
and i love the player uh we it looks
like the next episode they're still
gonna be around the stage we're gonna
jump ahead a little bit it looks like a
new baby on the way but soon in the
series we're gonna jump way ahead yeah
and that's when the real trouble is
going to start brewing it's moving it
was six months from the first and now
we're getting in it from the trailer it
looks like it's nine years at least nine
months oh yeah yeah it's probably
definitely but maybe a whole year i
don't know we'll see uh before we wrap
things up today let's do our power
rankings okay who do you think lost the
most power this episode dude he's down
bad right i hate this
i hate to say it but it's damon damon
sound bad
the lnt handed over that dragon egg and
it is now his
fiancee hates him in front of the city
the only guards he has yeah syria
walking off the bridge before it's all
said and done being like i forgot all
that man has now is his dragon which is
a lot don't get me wrong but he has no
one that should have that shot of him
like walking back through the tunnels of
dragonstone like beating and his his
girls in there and he's like she's just
like what the hell was all that about
she was like trying to get me killed out
there
this isn't our house it belongs to her
what are we doing yeah yeah she's like
i've been trafficked my whole life
used and abused and now you're just like
using me too yeah you're doing you made
some promises here and now now you're
doing it you're doing me dirty yeah she
she's down pretty bad i would say
she's higher than he is at least she has
respect for herself yeah cause even i
would say you know i think he certainly
lost the most power i think corliss
certainly lost a lot of power this
episode the thing is because everyone
knows everyone knows that he was pushing
his daughter and that
the king in front of everyone doesn't
choose her that's a big affront now he's
playing damon though which i kind of
like even though damon was like i talk
[ __ ] about my brother you don't get to
do that watch it my guy uh but i think
corliss is down pretty bad too i think
he's he got dinged on this one well i
think getting knocked down a peg is
different because he at least everyone
on the council was like no choose her
yeah choose that choose cordless is like
yeah they were pulling forth so it's
like it won't look too weird but also
it's like unfortunately unfortunately
nothing changes for him so that's fine
he's still on the he's still on the
council he's still under the king
nothing really changes so it's not like
he went down down he just stayed at his
normal rate okay who gained the most
power this episode allison
hightower easy making something
and that move was
more than a hop skip jump that was a
full fledge
into the sky
she got the stone masons to fix the
dragon even though you can still see the
glue mark i mean my guys
my wife would have never done this she
thought this was stupid she thought what
i was doing my wife thought my toys were
dumb but you're cool allison i like that
i would agree allison definitely gained
the most power i would have said regular
until that last scene i mean rainier
looked good this episode yeah she did
yeah picking who she wants for the
kingsguard
showing up on her dragon nobody even
knew she was there coming out of the fog
like a real champ she's definitely up
but i think i think you're right outside
the biggest she's a queen now she's a
queen she's a
queen are we able to are we allowed can
we on the right to that are we on the
rest of that let's check it let's check
it uh but i think that's it for this
episode of big question presents talking
dragons what an episode i'm so excited
to keep learning more and more
the targaryen family i love the second
episode the second episode was really
good it gave me game of thrones i was
screaming at my tv and it's been a long
time they gave us the hot action the
gore the first episode this was that
palace entrance
the whispers you choosing sides now
you're choosing sides you're choosing
teams and you're choosing sides uh well
be sure to check out check us out here
each and every week here on new
rockstars we're going to be spitting
fire with these targaryens every time
talking rings and kings and queens uh
it's all happening
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com be sure to grab
that latest obsession shirt uh follow me
at grin and barrack you can follow
jessica at lulu understood underscore
clements yeah that's right and make sure
to subscribe to bigquestion wherever you
get your podcast uh subscribe on youtube
or whatever podcast app you use thanks
for watching us we'll see you next time
bye-bye
[Music]
you